word
i'm sorry did a good job in getting it
but but we can't give you the prize and
it was the outing
will a fortune contestant charlene
receives what many fans of the show
believe she deserves
after she controversially lost an audi
q3 in december due to a timing rule on
the longtime game show that many were
unaware of
you have 10 seconds to try to talk it
out good luck
choosing the right card
charlene made it to the final round
where the category was called what are
you doing
though she guessed the wrong answer at
first she eventually said the right
phrase
choosing the right
word but it wasn't fast enough causing
her at the time to miss out on an audi
q3 this result set viewers off on social
media with some criticizing the abc show
for having hidden rules
jeopardy champion alex jacob tweeted
quote come on will a fortune the woman
literally chose the right word give her
the car
another viewer echoing that sentiment
tweeted quote she was right for pete's
sake will a fortune make it right some
of us who have been watching you for
decades are disgusted a viewer even
suggested that charlene should have a
gofundme page so she can quote get what
she deserves well there's no need for a
gofundme page now because audi has heard
the outcry loud and clear shortly after
the episode aired the company tweeted
quote you're a winner in our eyes
charlene now let's get you a prize time
to give her the q3 they followed up with
this tweet quote there's no community
like the audi community with your help
we track down charlene more to come as
we help give her the q3 and this past
thursday audi tweeted a photo of a
smiling charlene beaming with joy
standing next to her new car topped with
a big red bow holding up the car keys
they captioned the photo quote you all
did it you helped give her the q3
charlene welcome to the audi family
we're so happy to see you in the
driver's seat
now when it comes to will of fortune and
how long 74 year old pat sajak plans to
host the iconic game show
here's what he and his tv partner vanna
white told et in september i don't know
we're you know we're certainly close i
can speak for both of us we're certainly
closer to the end in the beginning
every time a contract comes up you think
about it i mean for me
i'd like to leave while the show's still
popular i'd like to leave while
i'd like to leave before people tune in
and look at me and say what happened to
him so uh you know we're getting close i
i don't know i'm not trying to be
teasing i i don't exactly know but it's
not i wouldn't bet on it seeing us in 10
years i would say is that fair probably
yes
you